we don't blame you for throwing shade
Maddie
after all you practically grew up on the
set of Dance Moms so you know a thing or
two about voicing your opinion if
there's one thing we do know is that
you're a reasonable person so we
wouldn't be surprised if the people you
shaded did something super Shady but
we'll give them the benefit of the doubt
for now Maddie Ziegler lost her appetite
for drama after leaving the cast of
Dance Moms but drama seems to follow her
everywhere she goes
watch until the end to find out what
happened between Maddie and Millie Bobby
Brown that's one thing I'm so happy
about do you know who's going on do you
know what Maddie Ziegler came up
together on Dance Moms they used to be
good friends
that is until Gina through some major
shade Maddie's way everything was going
great until Maddie and Gino were paired
up for a duet and instructed to kiss to
be fair Maddie probably hurt Gino's
feelings when she packed him on the lips
and ran away screaming she described the
kiss as disgusting but she was just a
kid and they were just friends so how
was she supposed to react do you know
fire back calling Maddie ugly amongst
many other things obviously Gino took
things way too far
Maddie later revealed that she stopped
being his friend after hearing what he
had said about her Abby Lee Miller it's
no secret that the Ziggler sisters and
their mother Melissa cut all contact
with Abby Lee Miller after leaving Dance
Moms during an interview with
Entertainment Tonight
Maddie basically confirmed that she and
Abby were done Maddie never went to see
Abby at the hospital and didn't care to
comment on her jail sentence but the
shadiest thing Manny ever did was leave
Abby out of her book the Maddie Diaries
a memoir Abby was shocked when she found
out she fired back by calling her former
student ungrateful
Chloe Lucchese ACK Maddie and Chloe used
to be best friends but everything
changed when the Lucchese acts left the
cast of Dance Moms in season four their
conflict in schedules prevented them
from hanging out like they used to and
both girls were pretty bummed about it
even though Abby Lee Miller pins Maddie
against Chloe for years the girls still
have a lot of love for each other
however Maddie
zero love for Dance Moms she referred to
the series as the worst when she found
out that Chloe was slated to return in
season seven really man he doesn't
understand why Chloe would choose to
return after everything Abby put them
through but we're sure that Lucchese axe
had their reasons Julianna to say that
Maddie Ziegler is competitive would be
an understatement
she won tons of titles and has a
reputation for snagging the number one
spot knowing this it's not too
surprising to find out that Maddie has
been shading people since she was 8
years old in season 1 episode 8 of Dance
Moms Maddie met her rivals Julianna at a
competition and she wasn't impressed I
think she's a really good dancer
but I think I have a good chance of
beating her but when it came time for
Maddie and Julianna to meet Maddie gave
Julianna the stink eye and totally sized
her up lilia buckingham on September 6
2019
Maddie guest-starred on the podcast the
sister diary although Maddie was very
careful not to name any names she did
throw some shade near the end of the
video and fans were certain that she was
talking about her former best friend
Lilia Buckingham Maddie talks about the
struggles of growing up under the public
eye and confessed that she had to let go
of some toxic friends over the last two
years since Lilia and Maddie don't
really talk anymore
we're guessing that Maddie was referring
to Lilia according to Maddie ditching
your old friends has made her so much
happier Shia LaBeouf back when Maddie
was 12 years old she starred in CEA's
music video alongside Shia LaBeouf see a
song elastic heart became an instant hit
and fans loved watching Maddie and Shia
danced around in a cage but during an
interview with Entertainment Tonight
Maddie revealed that working with Shia
wasn't a piece of cake she threw shade
his way when she told the world that
Shias hygiene wasn't on point I was like
I'm sorry
according to Maddie the actor smelled
terrible it was so bad that Maddie had
to ask Shia to put on some perfume
Millie Bobby Brown Maddie and Mila used
to be the cutest best friends ever but
their friendship started to fizzle out
in 2018 as it turns out Maddie thinks
that fame is getting to Millie's head
it's old news that Maddie wants to
transition into acting and since Millie
was cast as enola in the upcoming movie
series
Holmes Nadi asks Milly to try to get her
a roll but according to Hollywood scoop
Milly refused to pull some strings
she told Madi that she didn't want to
work with anyone she knew let alone her
best friends and while Matty took that
to heart
Madi and Millie's friendship took a sore
turn after these events Jack Kelly Matty
and Jack started dating back in 2017 but
the popular couple broke things off
after a year and a half of dating things
got pretty ugly when Annie unfollowed
jack on Instagram leading him to add a
very pretty message on his bio Jack
wrote good riddance on his page to show
his fans that he was happy about the
split Madi and Lilia returned to the
shade by posting themselves dancing to
shout out to my ex on Instagram so now
that you know all the details do you
agree with Madi
or do you think she's a little Shady
sound off in the comments for more
videos like this one hit that subscribe
button and be sure to give this video a
big thumbs up
thank you for watching we'll see you
next time on the things
[Music]